you leave home at 15 or 16. things
really worked out for you yeah you got a
record deal with that band I thought it
would you had a normal band called
choice I did I can't imagine what it was
like for you when you had to go to the
other two members of choice and say the
record company doesn't want you guys
anymore I wasn't allowed to say that
what do you mean I wasn't allowed to say
that
um I had to tell them that I wanted to
go solo
that was the deal oh because you had a
contract the record company said you've
got to decide if you want to go solo and
you have to tell those other two women
who are your good friends and if you
don't I'll shelve you for the rest of
your life I'll never let you out of your
contract you'll never do anything
oh no so I went home and called my dad
and I said I'm [__] and he said well
let's talk about this he's like so when
you were a little girl and you pictured
yourself up on stage what did you
picture
I said well I pictured myself he goes
sometimes we have to do hard things
so you went into the room and you said
to these two lovely women who you loved
I went into the room with my managers
first who managed all three of us and I
told them what was going on and they
said well you have to do it you have to
do it and then they went in the room
with the girls and said she's a [__]
cunning [__] and she's going to break
your heart
and then everyone disappeared I had no
record deal I had no management and then
I was homeless and so I met these guys
and I went to the Bronx and lived on
their floor and started writing songs
you went to your managers
and they betrayed you everyone
disappeared they said we got a it's got
a cool down for several months you know
we can't you know tortious interference
of a contract I'm 17 I'm like okay right
so uh how long do I have to get out of
the house
and then I basically renegotiated my own
contract for an outfit
from BB
and I got a job at a gas station then I
moved to the Bronx with these guys and I
we all got publishing deals together I
got myself a publishing deal
and I didn't know at the time that you
had to put it in writing you are no
longer my management
and at the meeting on the Monday morning
uh they showed up and then they sent me
for all of my money
and so you misunderstood I'd sold like
16 million records and I was broke like
penniless oh my God I wanted to write a
book called artist to artist how to get
[__] 101.